the first encounter we came up to in
Antarctica we pulled up in the zodiac
and we saw this massive leopard seal my
guide you Don has a lot of experience
with them said bloody hell that's the
biggest leopard seal I've ever seen time
to get in the water yeah and so I
slipped into the water terrified of what
might happen and I swam up to this
leopard seal and right away she opened
her mouth took my whole head and camera
inside her mouth and did these threat
displays but then the most amazing thing
happened
she started to feed me a penguin and she
started to take penguins and actually
push them into my camera I think she
thought the camera was my mom and she
kept trying to feed the camera which is
every photographers dream so here I came
to Antarctica to photograph this
potentially vicious animal to have this
this predator this top predator in
Antarctica take care of me and nurture
me and feed me for four days straight it
was the most incredible experience I've
ever had as a National Geographic
photographer